oh my god lee dude it's gonna be a great
morning and i'm all fired up here
um that
that leads me to this i got somebody
sent me this this morning
and it i'm gonna show this up to the
camera
it's a one of these pinteresty um
instagrammy why i crossfit
i being like the letter i because
everything's cool since it's like an
iphone
um why i crossfit
geez you take a cult and then you make
the cult hipster by putting an eye in
front of it that's just ridiculous
here's what it says because i can go
when you can't go any further because
easy will no longer suffice
because i just don't get better i get
better than great
and strive for perfection what does that
even mean because i know my limits and
defy them
daily because i don't stop when i'm
tired
when i'm tired i stop when i'm done when
i'm
done i can't even see it as a straight
face because i know
pain is weakness leaving the body
leaving the body
or pain is just a signal your body tells
you that crap's breaking but whatever
dude
because i have what it takes even if it
takes all that i've got
i don't even know what that means here's
my favorite because i don't use
because i don't use machines i have
become one
nope you haven't dude you're just a
person here's the thing i
hate i hate analogies that just
that describe people like machines like
um
dude i'm just letting off some steam or
i got my wires
crossed like you're a person man
you're a person yes i think people quit
too soon i think that most people
go through life um not finding out what
they're made of
i think people are not intentional with
their days and i don't think i think a
lot of people don't set goals
and they don't go through the hard hard
things to solve them
but this kind of nonsense makes the
author look goofy
and makes why i crossfit i being why i
have my iphone
in my ipad and i crossfit because i'm
greater than my obstacles you know what
that may be the the only grain of truth
here
we are greater than our obstacles when
you work hard and you have a community
around you
but also pain is a signal man pain is a
signal that you need to get in better
shape
pain is a signal that maybe i need to
take a day off and rest maybe i need to
have a gratitude journal maybe i need to
get with community
with people and for god's sake stop
referring to yourself as a machine
you're not a machine
you're a person we are not
machines to fill oil into and to
fix the gaskets bro we are people that
need to love that need to have goals
need to have community
and they need to work together stumbling
and bumbling and sometimes sprinting and
sometimes
resting towards wherever it is we're
headed as
a community
you